شادي الدول الاوروبيه ارتفاعا غير مسبوق
في درجات الحراره خلال فتره الاعياد طبعا
مقارنه باحوال الطقس خلال نفس الفتره في
الماضي وفق المنظمه العالميه للارصاد
الجويه المنظمه قالت ان درجات الحراره
خلال اول ايام العيد العام الجديد ارتفعت
الى اكثر من 20 درجه مئويه في الكثير من
الدول الاوروبيه وحتى في اوروبا الوسطى
قالت اللجنه الحكوميه الدوليه المعنيه
بالمناخ ان التراجع الشديد في الغطاء
الثلجي والكتل الجليديه وفتره تساقط
الثلوج في الاماكن المرتفعه سيستمر اشارها
موقع اخبار الامم المتحده الى ان عددا
متزايدا من منتجعات التزلج الاوروبيه لم
تتمكن من توفير الغطاء الثلجي الكافي
للزوار في ظل ظروف الطقس غير المعتاده